it was outside of his own clothing store
in South Los Angeles that Nipsey Hussle
was shot police say by a man who walked
up to the rapper and the two people with
him and opened fire he was shot in the
neighborhood where he'd grown up
shocking fans and friends alike I just
met with him last week he had me bring
my daughter so he can work with her
she's a model I couldn't believe it
because I was just like you know I was
like just left Church and then someone
said Nipsey Hussle just and I was just
like no way how in his final tweet not
long before he was shot
Nipsey Hussle had written having strong
enemies is a blessing hey Sean ah merci
aura was gone back to back it was the
mix tapes that Nipsey Hussle began
releasing more than a decade ago that
propelled him to a career working with
some of the industry's biggest names
some of them pay tribute Rihanna
posting this doesn't make any sense my
spirit is shaken by this and Pharrell
Williams tweeted you inspired millions
millions who will uphold your legacy
forever
[Music]
lipsi had spoken about growing up in the
gang world of South LA he'd launched
projects there to help turn young people
away from gang life his partner the
actress Lauren London had given birth to
the couple's first child three years ago
to many well-known and not
Nipsey Hussle was an influence and an
inspiration he died at the age of 33
Greg Milam Sky News Los Angeles